from the branching perspective
you mentioned regrets uh
do you have regrets about your own
trajectory oh yeah of course
yeah some of it's painful but you want
to hear the painful stuff no
i'd say like in terms of working with
people
when people did say stuff i didn't like
especially if it was a bit nefarious
i took it personally and i also felt it
was personal about them
but a lot of times like humans are you
know most humans are a mess
right and then they act out and they do
stuff and i this psychologist
i heard a long time ago said you tend to
think
somebody does something to you but
really what they're doing is they're
doing what they're doing while they're
in front of you
it's not that much about you yeah right
and
as i got more interested in
you know when i work with people i think
about them and
probably analyze them and understand
them a little bit and then when they do
stuff i'm way less surprised and i'm
wait you know and if it's bad i'm way
less
hurt and i react way less like i sort of
expect everybody's got their [ __ ]
yeah and it's not about you it's not
about me that much
it's like you know you know you do
something and you think you're
embarrassed but nobody cares
like and somebody's really mad at you
the odds of it being about
you yeah no they're getting mad the way
they're doing that because of some
pattern they learned
and you know and maybe you can help them
if you care enough about it
but or you could step you could see it
coming and step out of the way
like like i wish i was way better at
that i'm a bit of a hothead
and you said with steve that was a
feature not a bug
yeah well he was using it as the counter
force the orderliness that would crush
his work well you were doing the same
yeah maybe i don't think i don't think
my uh my vision was big enough it was
more like i just got pissed off
and did stuff i'm sure that's just
yeah yeah you're telling me i don't know
if it had the
it didn't have the amazing effect of
creating the trillion dollar company it
was more like i just got
pissed off and left and or
made enemies that he shouldn't have been
yeah it's hard
like i didn't really understand politics
until i worked at apple
where you know steve was a master player
of politics and his staff had to be or
they wouldn't survive them and
it was definitely part of the culture
and then i've been in companies where
they say it's political but it's all
you know fun and games compared to apple
and it's not that
the people apple are bad people it's
just they operate politically at a at a
higher level
you know it's not like oh somebody said
something bad about somebody
somebody else which is most politics
it's you know they had strategies about
accomplishing their goals
sometimes you know over the dead bodies
of their enemies
you know with some communication yeah
more game of thrones and sophistication
than like a big time factor rather than
a
you know well that requires a lot of
control over your emotions i think
uh to do to have a bigger strategy in
the way you behave
yeah and it's it's it's effective in the
sense that coordinating thousands of
people to do really hard things
where many of the people in there don't
understand themselves much less how
they're participating yeah
creates all kinds of you know drama and
problems
that you know our solution is political
in nature
like how do you convince people how do
you leverage them how do you motivate
them how do you get rid of them how you
know like there's
there's so many layers of that that are
interesting
and even though some some of it let's
say may be tough
it's not uh evil
unless you know you use that skill to
evil purposes which some people
obviously do
but it's a skill set that operates you
know and i wish i'd
you know i was interested in it but i
you know it was sort of like i'm an
engineer i do my thing
and you know there's there's times when
i could have way bigger impact
if i you know knew how to if i paid more
attention and knew more about that
about the human layer of the stack yeah
that human political
power you know expression layer of the
stack just complicated
and there's lots to know about it i mean
people are good at it are just amazing
and when they're good at it and let's
say
relatively kind and oriented a good
direction
you can really feel it can get lots of
stuff done and coordinate things you
never thought possible
but all people like that also have some
pretty hard edges because
you know it's a heavy lift and i wish
i'd spent more time with that when i was
younger
but maybe i wasn't ready you know i was
a wide-eyed kid for 30 years
a little bit of a kid i know
you